j'ai mis des tranches de fromage ça
commence bien dans les baskets de
maryval pour Kane pour qu'il me préfère
de tranche de fromage c'est tout propre
d'amour relative ça
c'est une femme à Marival
il y en a par exemple sur ce plateau qui
n'ont pas besoin de mettre des tranches
de fromage pour faire quelque chose
en fait on était dans un club de un camp
de vacances pour les ados en fait voilà
une colonie de vacances exactement
colonie de vacances il y avait le beau
gosse etc et je sentais qu'il hésitait
quand même entre deux et on était un peu
voilà deux sur le dos et c'était donc
l'été donc il faisait chaud et elle
avait une paire de basket et en fait à
un moment donné je sais pas pourquoi
j'ai eu cette idée il y avait on avait
on devait se faire des sandwichs comme
ça voilà et il y avait des espèces de
tranches de fromage vous savez mais déjà
fines
mais c'était tellement évident pour moi
j'ai vu ses baskets j'ai vu les tranches
de fromage j'ai dit j'ai pas les mettre
dans le pain je vais les fous de lancer
les baskets et en fait ce que j'ai fait
c'était c'est ingénieux j'ai pris la
semelle à l'intérieur de ça
donc j'ai pris la semaine comme ça elle
a passé 15 jours avec du lait d'ammer
dans ces pompes là
pas mal
c'était génial
[Applaudissements]
c'était parfait et j'ai remis dans le
truc et ça a fonctionné
et du coup il a kiffé quand même
je me suis retrouvé je me suis retrouvé
par -32 degrés en haut d'une montagne au
Canada quand même ça c'est génial
je sortais avec j'étais amoureuse d'un
champion de ski et donc il m'a très bon
dans le papier de bateau
et donc voilà et je l'ai suivi un petit
peu sur le parcours des des
compétitions et je me suis retrouvé dans
des vêtements pas du tout adaptés
évidemment j'essayais d'être un peu
mignonne et à moins 30 j'avais pas
vraiment jaugé ce que ça voulait dire
moins 30 degrés c'est terrible c'est à
dire que le nez
se ferme comme ça parce que tout congèle
en un instant c'est assez terrible voilà
en fait
tous les orifices gênent en fait c'est
le principe il a
alors j'ai fait demi-tour sur
l'autoroute car j'avais oublié le bisou
du matin
oui j'ai fait demi-tour
on peut pas faire demi-tour sur
l'autoroute
et c'est vrai parce que le matin c'est
toujours c'est une petite tradition le
bisou bonne journée c'est comme ça on
adore ça et si c'est ça de canard et ben
je suis un coin quoi
je suis parti je lui ai fait le bisou je
suis je devais aller à l'aéroport je
suis allé à l'aéroport j'ai raté mon
avion c'était pour un casting je suis
rentré qu'est-ce que tu fais mais j'ai
loupé mon avion donc tu vas regroupé et
je me suis fait démonter parce qu'elle
me dit tu es rentré tu m'as fait le
bisou je veux bien mais tu as loupé ton
avis tu as loupé ton casting et j'ai
passé une journée de merde
quelle série c'était un autre épisode de
Camping Paradis je me suis bien fait
engueuler ah alors ça c'est ça c'est une
brève vraie preuve d'amour par amour
j'ai mis un slip
j'ai toujours des slipop
normalement
[Applaudissements]
non
ça fonctionne
voilà il faut faire attention quand même
hein
moi je veux dire moi je mets des boxs
[Rires]
voilà donc j'ai créé sur les réseaux un
faux compte avec la photo d'une
mannequin pour lui reparler car on était
séparé ça déjà c'est une bonne méthode
hein
j'étais séparée du père de mon fils il
ne voulait plus entendre parler de moi
il voulait plus me parler bon voilà
est-ce que c'est vrai
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé avec le mari
est-ce qu'il s'est passé donc moi je
voulais le reconquérir j'ai créé
effectivement un faux compte j'ai trouvé
une nana mannequin hyper belle je savais
que c'était sa carte
donc j'ai trouvé la photo de quelqu'un
d'autre et donc j'ai commencé à lui
parler et en fait il est il est devenu
fou de cette nana parce que un était
très belle et deux comme moi je le
connaissais très bien bah ouais
exactement donc on a parlé pendant des
semaines et des semaines sauf qu'à un
moment donné je me suis il voulait me
voir
surprise donc je lui ai dit et alors je
lui ai dit écoute j'ai quelque chose à
t'annoncer à te dire on se connaît et il
me dit je suis ta femme
je dis on se connaît et il me dit je
crois que donc j'ai deviné ce que ton
prénom commence par la lettre A je dis
oui effectivement c'est moi et en fait
il avait un peu capté il était rentré
dans le dans le jeu
10 minutes après il a sonné à ma porte
et on s'est remis ensemble
je suis resté caché dans le local
poubelle de l'immeuble où mon ex avait
un studio déjà
[Musique]
[Rires]
parce que vous vous êtes beaucoup en
fait maîtresse j'ai pas beaucoup parce
que mais enfin oui et donc voilà c'était
l'acteur connu est arrivé il a fallu que
je me cache dans le local poubelle
combien de temps tu es resté dans le
local 3 ans
[Rires]
c'était toujours le l'acteur connu
c'était toujours voilà
dans un immeuble voilà
il est plus de ce monde
bravo bravo bravo alors j'ai fait Paris
Madrid en scooter en plein hiver
alors Paris Madrid
en scooter
combien 50 300 mais je vous le conseille
pas
c'est à peu près 12 heures 12 heures
ou alors le train là je peux expliquer
comme chaque chroniqueur l'a fait
allez-y vite alors en réalité c'était
après l'émission était 21h j'ai essayé
de prendre le dernier vol j'ai pas
réussi et c'était très simple danger de
mort donc j'ai dû trouver le seul moyen
qui me permettait de d'aller en Espagne
et c'était le scooter et donc c'était
très très long le problème c'est que
quand on arrive et qu'on a fait si plein
d'essence en plein hiver
ont pu la mort on a le dos qui est en
compote mais le problème c'est que une
fois qu'on a sauvé notre coupe faut
revenir après
il fallait mettre dans le train après ça
existe plus ça en tout cas pas depuis
l'Espagne donc c'était très compliqué je
le conseille à personne ça c'est une
vraie preuve d'amour
la prochaine fois vaut mieux être
célibataire parce que c'est très
compliqué et chaque matin je respecte le
premier quoi le premier vous savez pas
lire
benjaminer ferme ta gueule
c'est toute la vie ferme ta gueule
est-ce que je parle beaucoup le matin je
lui raconte ma vie j'ai besoin de parler
ça l'insulte elle va être tranquille
elle boisson café elle se prépare donc
on a instauré ça et ça marche très bien
je ferme ma gueule pendant une heure et
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait beau par amour
par amour par amour qu'est-ce que j'ai
fait par amour pas grand chose pas grand
chose non je suis pas un grand grand
romantique en vérité je crois si allez
j'ai envie de dire
j'ai fait la surprise alors que j'étais
encore à en rééducation voilà sortie de
l'hôpital de de débarquer chez moi pour
la première fois pour faire la surprise
à ma compagne
je suis en train de réfléchir ce que
j'ai fait par amour
qu'est-ce que j'en ai fait des conneries
par amour
[Rires]
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait par amour
je suis revenu c'est ma femme voulait
pas une de mes fan une femme une
personne ne voulait pas prendre l'avion
toute seule pour faire Paris Los Angeles
et moi j'étais au Mexique non donc j'ai
fait pas j'ai fait Mexico Paris je suis
reparti avec elle pour aller à Los
Angeles
de carte bleue